welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer security
mechanisms
so in this video we're going to look at
the different mechanisms that we use to
keep computers secure on the network and
you'll recall from the last lecture
uh we talked about four different
network security concerns
confidentiality
making sure that our communications are
confidential and nobody is able to
eavesdrop
authentication being able to determine
that the person who we're talking to is
who they say they are
integrity making sure that our messages
aren't tampered with and non-repudiation
being able to determine whether or not
somebody actually carried out a
particular action
in a way such that they can't repudiate
it
the mechanisms we're going to be talking
about now are going to take care of
these different problems
these all fit under the general umbrella
cryptography
which is a study of how to send secure
messages
they're going to depend on encryption
techniques encryption means to take
a plain text message and convert it to
an encrypted ciphertext message and
decryption
which is the reverse process taking the
ciphertext message and converting it
back to the original plain text
now we've been doing encryption for
thousands of years and so i'm going to
start off by showing you how the caesar
cipher works this is a
pretty simple cipher that you'll all be
able to understand quite easily
and it was used by julius caesar so you
can see we've been encrypting for quite
some time
okay the way the caesar cipher works is
we shift letters in the message by three
letters so
uh if i've got a message and i've got
the letter a in the original text i'm
going to go ahead and shift that a
b c d and instead of writing the a i'm
going to write a d
instead of writing a b i'm going to say
b c d
e okay if i shift b over by three
characters i get an e
and so i'm going to write an e instead
of a b i'm going to write it f
instead of a c and so on all right so
let's take a look at the caesar cipher
in action
so suppose the tas are
unhappy with how i'm running the class
and they decide that they are going to
meet for lunch and plot a
coup d'etat so they're concerned
because they know i'm a tyrannical guy
so
they don't want me to know that they're
meeting and so they're going to take
their
uh message here meet for lunch and
they're going to encrypt it using the
caesar cipher so
the m if we shift it over by 3 mnop
the e becomes efgh
the t becomes t u v w
and so on and so you can see that meat
for lunch becomes
phhw iru 0xqfk
and just again as a reminder we refer to
the original text as plain text and the
converted text as ciphertext
now i play the role of mallory here i'm
the bad guy
and so i intercept the tas texts
and i see phhw iru
0x qfk i think
huh i seem to recall ireu stands for
something this must be some new
newfangled kids internet speak i guess
they're just having fun
i have nothing to worry about uh
everything's going great
and um so the tas are able to meet for
lunch
and replace me and they will be teaching
lecture
shortly this is actually a true story
because ivy who is one of our tas will
be teaching the lectures on artificial
intelligence because
she is far more of an expert on modern
artificial intelligence than i am i
actually have a master screen artificial
intelligence but
it's from 1986 so i think things have
changed a bit since
then all right anyway back to the caesar
cipher
all right so just as a reminder um
we have encryption and decryption so
alice is going to start with a plain
text
meet for lunch she's going to generate
the ciphertext p-h-h-w-i-r-u-0x
qfk and then when bob receives that
ciphertext he's going to have to pass it
back to the decryption algorithm
in order to understand what the heck
alice is actually trying to tell him
all right there's actually if you think
about it there's actually two components
to the caesar cipher there's the general
shifting algorithm
and then the z-mount to shift so
apparently augustus caesar actually
used the same shifting algorithm as
julius caesar did but he changed the
amount to shift
it's still shocking to me that uh their
opponents could not figure out the
cipher but
they didn't um which brings us to the
next question
why am i shocked that this cipher
actually worked
because there's a lot of problems with
the caesar cipher the main one being the
key size is way too small
if we're using english letters you can
only shift
up to 26 characters and in fact the 26th
character actually rolls around to the
original character so
arguably you only have 25 characters
because the 26
is useless um and so this is susceptible
to what's called a brute force attack
and so the idea behind
a brute force attack is i just try all
the different
combinations of characters until i use
one of them
and it results in something that looks
like
normal english text i'm like oh that
must be the meaning of the message
but it turns out that the caesar cipher
is not just bad because there's only a
very limited number of keys
it's also bad because it's susceptible
to cryptanalysis and so a cryptanalysis
means is that
we take a look at the ciphertext and
we're able to discern information about
uh the message and the key just by
looking at
the the text and so if we look at this
text
i p-h-h-w u 0 x q f k the thing that
immediately stands out to me
is that pair of h's next to each other
now how many letters are there in the
english language that
you can get two of them right next to
each other i mean there are there's more
than just two of them but
there aren't that many of them offhand
you could have two o's next to each
other
like look you can obviously have two e's
next to each other i think you can have
two l's next to each other
but you know there aren't that many
letters which you can have two of next
to each other and it'd still be a word
in the english language
and moreover this particular message
doesn't have
uh this particular weakness but um if we
have a message that has a
word with a single character in it
there's
also a very limited number of messages
that can only have a single character in
it like
i or a and so if we're
caesar's opponents and we're
intercepting a bunch of these messages
over time we're going to see messages
with these pairs of duplicate letters
we're going to see messages
with single letter words and over time
we're going to be able to reduce the
amount of possible keys
far below the original 26 and so
the caesar ciphers just seem super super
weak and it's a little scary to believe
that uh
and apparently this is true this was
used by julie caesar
um shocking
i like using it though because it's it's
something that you know people
students can look at and they're like
okay i kind of get that and so
the same general process is going to be
used with real ciphers
uh real modern ciphers although the
conversion to the ciphertext is going to
be much more complex and
mathematically based if we look at the
caesar cipher there's actually
two different things that are keeping
these messages safe
the first one is the number of keys and
as we saw that's
really weak with the caesar cipher
although in a modern
cipher that's that is really the thing
that's keeping you safe you just need a
really big key
and the second thing is what the
algorithm is and
presumably what was keeping the caesar
cipher safe was the algorithm people
didn't realize that this was a shifting
algorithm
and so they just looked at the message
and they just thought it was gibberish
and didn't know how to break the code
but it might surprise you to learn that
modern encryption algorithms are all
public so
if you want to know the algorithm being
used to send
encrypted traffic on the internet well
it's publicly available and you can take
a look at it
why do we tell everybody what algorithm
we're using
well the hope here is that um
you know we're concerned that the black
hat hackers the bad
guys are going to be trying to break
these algorithms and
steal all of our information um
and the hope is that the white hat
hackers or security experts
the good guys are going to analyze
our encryption algorithm and determine
if they're susceptible to cryptanalysis
and actually stanford's been involved in
several of these efforts and there are
encryption outcomes that were formally
used that are not being used anymore
because of work by a stanford
computer scientist so there you go white
hat hackers in action
um one thing i should mention is that
a lot of the things that i say about
keys are actually also true
passwords so keys and passwords aren't
the same but there definitely are strong
similarities so
passwords like keys are susceptible for
to brute force attack so with the key
you try all the different combinations
with passwords you just try all the
different combinations of letters or
letters to numbers
um until you hit the one that matches
uh the original the person's original
password
and as with the keys where you know the
problem with the caesar cipher is there
are only 25 or 26 keys
um with passwords longer
passwords are much better but also
passwords are
susceptible to analysis and
there are certain passwords that are
nice and long but that are used by a lot
of other people and so
that would be a really bad idea to use
those hackers have list of the most
common passwords so
um you know you really want a long
password that it's completely random
we'll talk more about passwords in
another lecture but uh
i just know what usually when i'm
talking on this subject
the students get a little confused
because some of the things that we say
about these keys
seems to be related to passwords and yes
there are strong similarities between
the two
all right so the caesar cipher is what
we refer to as a symmetric
encryption technique in symmetric
encryption the same
key is used for encrypting and
decrypting so with the traditional
caesar cipher is used by julius caesar
the
key is three so both the person who's
encoding needs to know that
they're shifting it by three and whoever
receives the message knows that they
need to decrypt it by
shifting back by three so uh the same
key is used for encrypting and
decrypting
there's another encryption technique
called asymmetric encryption where we
have two keys
one key is used for encrypting and the
other key is used for decrypting and it
turns out having two different keys is
super super useful
now the two keys have to be
mathematically related to each other
and they are going to be generated as
pairs
and if we have one of the keys in the
pair
we can't be able to determine the other
key in the pair
easily because if i can get from one key
to the other key
uh this these keys are gonna be useless
for asymmetric encryption so
they're generated together at the same
time
um and but if somebody gets a hold of
one of the keys
but doesn't have the other key they
can't be able to reverse engineer it to
figure out what the matching key is that
would be bad
and if they are able to do it then we're
uh we're completely vulnerable
so symmetric encryption has been around
for pretty much forever
as as we've seen from our example the
caesar cipher
asymmetric encryption on the other hand
is quite recent it was first published
by diffie hellman
in 1976 and the hellman
in diffie hellman is actually martin
hellman who's a professor in stanford's
ee department
and is the winner of the turing award
which you'll recall is
the equivalent of a nobel prize in
computer science uh
i guess when alfred noble was creating
the
nobel prizes there was no computer
science at the time so
we didn't get one of them so we made up
our own which is a turing award
and professor helmut is the winner of
the touring award
it turns out it was also discovered by
the british intelligence government
communications headquarters in 1973
but they didn't publish the work
asymmetric encryption is sometimes
referred to as public key private key
encryption or sometimes just simply as
public key
and as these names apply making one of
the keys public is
often very useful and it will allow us
to solve a bunch of the problems that we
looked at um
when we were talking about network
security issues
so one of the problems with symmetric
encryption is the problem of how
somebody gets a key so suppose i am
communicating with amazon and i want to
communicate with them in a secure manner
i'm going to provide them with
information like my credit card
how can we make sure we're shopping
securely on amazon
if we've got symmetric encryption we
know we need to have a shared key we're
both using the same key for encrypting
and decrypting we both have that key
and it needs to be very long because
remember longer is better
longer is more secure and so the big
question that comes up is how do i get
the key
well think about that for a minute how
am i going to get the key from amazon
um well one obvious thing is they could
email to me
that turns out to work because email is
not secure
and in fact i can't think of a good way
for amazon to get that key to me
other than through snail mail uh but
you know snail mail is you know sending
to the u.s postal service that's a
really bad idea
from their standpoint i mean it will
work but that means i would put a bunch
of stuff in my shopping cart
the first time i went to amazon and i'd
be like okay i'm ready to check out and
they'd be like
oh well we're going to mail you this key
um through the u.s postal service and it
will probably take three days but it
might take longer
and when you get it you can enter the
key into the web browser
and then you can send us a credit card
like
yeah i'm pretty sure they would lose a
lot of people
just at the shopping cart right at that
point the other problem is
take a look at what the key looks like
so this is the actual key that
amazon has you can see it doesn't
actually fit you can see the little
scroll bar there on the right
if amazon were to mail this to me it
would be on the printed page
and i would have to
enter in all these hexadecimal digits
and not get any of them wrong
in order to communicate securely with
amazon using symmetric encryption
okay this is totally not happening all
right so
how does asymmetric encryption solve our
problem very easily
amazon takes one of their keys says this
key is going to be the public key
and they just put it up on their website
in fact we just saw it a minute ago
that's their public key
um and then when i want to talk to
amazon
i take their public key and i encrypt
whatever i want to send to amazon with
that public key
and anyone intercepting our traffic can
see that i'm sending information amazon
they know it was encrypted with the
public key they also have access to that
public key
but that public key doesn't decrypt
messages that were encrypted with it
we need the private key in order to
decrypt the message we don't have the
private key
and as long as amazon keeps their
private key private
i can encrypt messages and send it to
amazon and nobody else can read it so
we are now able to uh communicate with
amazon and secure manner
now usually what's going to happen with
websites like amazon
all the other websites work the same way
um
i'm going to start off with an
asymmetric encryption
because that's you know they're going to
provide me with their public key
and i'm going to encrypt something and
send it to them uh
and they're the only ones that are going
to be able to read it because they're
the ones with the private key
but as soon as we can we're going to
generate a symmetric key
that only the two of us use the only the
two of us know
and that's what we're actually going to
use for regular communication because it
turns out symmetric encryption is
computationally cheaper than asymmetric
encryption and since their web
server is decrypting all these messages
anything they can do to register is the
load on the server it's going to be
better for them
it's going to be cheaper for them
okay i mentioned that email is not
secure
generally not secure it is certainly
possible to create a secure email system
using public key private key
and in fact there is a system out there
it's just not very widely used
uh okay so how do we create a secure
email system using public keys
well basically everybody just publishes
their public key
and then if somebody wants to send them
a message they just take that public key
they encrypt the message with that
public key they
send it through the internet everybody
can see all the traffic sent through the
internet but
uh you know if somebody sees
that message on the internet it's
encrypted with the public key
they also have access to the public key
but they don't have access to the key
that they need to decrypt it that's the
private key and so the email is secure
um public key private key can also be
used for non-repudiation so here's
you'll recall this is our
non-repudiation example from
last uh last video so suppose
i send out a message i say no final exam
maybe i'm drunk or something and on a
lark
uh i decided to send out this no final
exam message and then later the next day
i'm like
oh god did i actually send a message
there was no final exam oh
crap i didn't mean to do that i'm going
to take it back i'm going to tell them
that wasn't me must have been somebody
else must been maddie
uh that actually is not a very good
example because if maddie actually has
access to my computer she could totally
send it uh in a way that would violate
our little example here so anyway so
i'll talk about that in a minute when i
tell you how this all works all right so
uh the way we have non-repudiation is
if my system is set up so that when i
send that message
no final exam i actually encrypt no
final exam with my
private key and you guys all receive it
and you decrypt it with my public key
now you can be like patrick you must
have sent that message
because only you have the private key
that could be used to encrypt the
message in such a way that we can
decrypt it with your public key
so therefore you can't repudiate you
must have sent this
okay going back to our example maddie
and maddie actually has access to my
computer
um she's sleeping under the coffee table
right now
uh if if maddie actually has access to
my computer and
uh you know my private key sitting there
on my computer and probably
my whole email system set up to use the
private key um
you know she could totally send the
message so basically
this whole system is only as secure as
your private key is
secure
asymmetric encryption is also used to
identify websites
uh the way this works is that there are
a number what are referred to as
certification authorities that are
responsible for certifying websites
the most common certification
authorities have public keys which are
built into your web browser
it's also possible to add additional
certification authorities
by explicitly adding their public keys
to the web browser i don't recommend
doing this in general
so if you go visit certain websites you
may get a message that
oh this website is certified by such and
such a certification authority which
the web browser doesn't know about
should i add this certification
authority to your list of certification
authorities
and in general i don't think there are
good reasons
for a website to not use one of the
standard certification authorities
at this point so just be aware if you
say yes
that means other websites certified by
this potentially sketchy certification
authority are also going to
be assumed to be legitimate by your web
browser and that may not be something
that you want to do so
be cautious adding additional
certification authorities to your web
browser
so the way this is going to work is a
website that wants a certificate
is going to contact the certification
authority and they will provide
sufficient identification to the
certification authority
to convince the certification authority
that they are who they say they are
and then the certification authority is
going to take their information
and generate a certificate using the
certification authority's private key
and so uh you have the public key built
into the web browser
and the certification authority has the
private key used to generate the
certificate the certificate is going to
be placed on the website and when we
visit the website we will download the
certificate to the web browser
the web browser will attempt to decrypt
it and if it can be decrypted with the
public key built into the web browser
than we know was actually issued by the
certification authority
the certificate includes the website's
public key
and we use the public key to initiate
communication with the website
notice that this system does depend upon
the certification authorities correctly
vetting those who ask for certificates
and also keeping their private key safe
and secure and it turns out that
sadly both of these have failed at
various points with this
certification authorities there's been
at least one case that i'm aware of
where
a certificate was authorized and given
to somebody claiming to be microsoft and
it turned out they weren't microsoft
and there's also been a case where the
certification authority itself was
hacked
and uh their private key was stolen so
great job guys when you are
communicating with a website that has a
certificate and is
you you're going to be communicating
using https
instead of http so
standard non-secure communications on
the web uses http
secure communications uses https which
is a secure variant of http
and when we are using https that means
that
all of our traffic to and from that
website is being encrypted
okay let's go back to our list of uh
network concerns that we had before so
confidentiality um being able to
communicate in a secure manner such that
if somebody's trying to eavesdrop they
can't read our communication
well we've seen that both symmetric and
asymmetric encryption takes care of that
authentication we've just seen that with
the certification authorities
the certification authorities use public
key private key in order to
provide certificates that guarantee that
a website is who they say they are
non-repudiation we saw that public key
private key could be used to
set up a system where people could not
repudiate actions that they had taken
and then that leaves integrity which we
haven't talked about yet so let's take a
quick look at integrity
the simplest way to generate integrity
is
to use a checksum and
check some there's a variety of
different ways to check some but
the simplest way to do it that i think
students
understand intuitively is you just take
all the different
values of that are contained in the file
you treat all those bits as numbers and
add all the bits together
um now it's going to come up with a
really big number so
you probably want to chop off a whole
bunch of the high-end bits
and you basically do a modulus if you're
familiar with the modulus it's a
sort of a remainder integer remainder
and then you go ahead and take
the remaining value and use it as your
checksum all right so the way this is
going to work
is if you transfer say a file over the
internet
um originally the person that created
the file is going to create that
checksum
they're going to either include it with
the file
or they will send it separately from the
file
your computer will receive the file it
will go back through and add everything
up
to to see what checksum it gets and if
the two checksums match
then you know that there's a good chance
that the file was not in fact corrupted
now um it's possible for
the file to be get corrupted in just
such a way that the checksum is still
the same so that is a possibility but
it's unlikely the problem with checksums
though is
since it's pretty easy to understand how
the checksum is generated it's also
pretty easy to
reverse engineer things so that you
manipulate the file in just such a way
that the checksum remains the same so
this is
actually kind of a problem i should also
mention that you may run into checksum
if you download a zip file you'll you
will occasionally run into zip files
where it says there's a checksum error
and so that's what's going on with those
it's saying hey we calculated the
checksum when we generated the zip file
and now uh when we're unzipping it we're
double checking to check some and they
don't match so
something went wrong here you know
either
it was uh you downloaded over the
internet and some of the bits got
twiddled
or you know maybe somehow got corrupted
on one end or the other
end but somehow we know that the
checksum is not the original checksum
for
the files when we originally generated
the zip file so something is wrong here
so that's probably the most likely place
you're going to run into checksum
all right um so as i mentioned uh a
malicious attacker can
manipulate the file in just such a way
to maintain the checksum so
uh there's another technique we can use
called a hash
or a cryptographic hash these work
similar to the check sound but
they work in such a way that it's it's
much more difficult for somebody to
try and manipulate the file in such a
way that we end up with the exact same
hash
so these are going to guarantee but from
both accidental
changes which is what our checksum did
but they will also guarantee against
deliberate corruption of the data
you will occasionally run into these
when you download things from websites
particularly software that's open source
so here um i used a program called
audacity much earlier in the quarter
actually the first week of the quarter
when we were talking about computer
music
it was a program where i was playing
music to the computer and it was showing
us what the waveform looked like
if you go to the audacity website they
don't actually
host the audacity files themselves
because
it costs a lot of money to serve up
copies of the audacity files to
everybody that asks for them
so instead they have a bunch of other
people you can download
the files from and they want to make
sure that
whoever gives you a copy the audacity
source files
has not somehow corrupted it and added
in some sort of malicious thing in their
code
we'll talk about the different malicious
things you could put in the code
actually next lecture
so what they've done is they've provided
the different checksums and so you can
see they have a whole bunch of checksums
because there's a
copy of audacity for windows there's a
copy for mac there's a copy for
unix and so on and so forth and so each
of these
is a different file and it has different
code involved
and therefore it has its own checksum
and so the idea here
is that you would download the file from
a third party um you would
get a hold that file and you would run
something to generate the cryptographic
hash so it turns out it is marked as
checksums but these are actually using a
cryptographic hash technique
and that sah256 that you see
in front of each of these checksums that
is actually the specific cryptographic
hash function
that you need to run in order to get
that number back so you would go ahead
and download
one of these files from from
either from audacity itself which i
think redirects to
other people's websites or maybe you get
it from a friend or somebody
you want to just double check to make
sure that this file is in fact what it
says it is
and so what you would do is you would
take that file
you would run the sha-256 algorithm on
it
that would generate this big long number
and you would compare the big long
number that the sha256 generated from
the file that you have
with the number published on the
audacity website as the correct checksum
and if the two match that tells us that
uh
this is in fact the original file that
audacity came up with
and if it doesn't match that's pretty
bad
it could just mean that um the file was
just corrupted in
network transit or it could mean
somebody has deliberately inserted
something at the file
like maybe they've added some adware to
it some spyware or something else
even nastier to it and again we'll be
talking about
different nasty things people can do
with files in effect
in the very next lecture so i will talk
to you then